if you were an evil individual record
executive that wanted to extract as much
wealth from the artists that you
possibly could given the technology that
exists right now MH how would it look
easy money okay um you create somebody
who is the most radical Persona in image
of Counter Culture as possible and feed
the hits you've heard from the CEO
you've heard from the drug deal you've
heard from the stripper you've heard
from this it's going to go to the next
and then the next and then the next and
then the next it's more extreme oh yeah
bro give it 10 years and legitimate like
where it's like clear that that's their
brand we have a number one song in the
world and it is a known crackhead and we
will be living in a Black Mirror episode
where everyone is rooting and cheering
on for the train w